Several differences that we saw in the OCL from the First-Order Logic. It uses
the vertical bar, not only, to get at the length of things, but I'm sorry.
Not not as we saw in the First-Order Logic to indicate the length of things,
but it serves the role as the dot we saw before to separate the part which is
saying. What the, what the variable is from the remainder.
The limitations on the value of i appear as part of the proposition itself.
The limitations on the value of i are separated from the proposition itself,
by the use of the implies OCL keyword. I've also cheated a bit,
by using OCL's built in sequence class instead of vectors.
OCL doesn't have vectors, it has sequences, but those are essentially the same.